républicain la parole à monsieur yannick
moreau à quelques jours des élections
régionales au coeur de la coop 21
je vous invite monsieur le premier
ministre à regarder l'avenir de la
france en bleu le bleu de notre planète
qui s'échauffent et se réchauffent le
bleu de la mer source inépuisable
d'inspiration d'énergies marines
renouvelables et de biodiversité à venir
de la terre la mer recèle de trésors et
de secrets qu'il nous faudra tout à la
fois savoir préserver et percer le bleu
également du drapeau européen qui
flottera sur le conseil des ministres de
la pêche qui se réunira dans quelques
jours à bruxelles
comme tous les ans la roulette
bruxelloise décidera sans appel de droit
de vie ou de mort sur des dizaines de
port des centaines d'armement des
milliers d'entreprises familiales
individuelle et française les marins
pêcheurs monsieur le premier ministre
compte sur vous non seulement pour les
défendre mais aussi pour leur ouvrir
enfin une lisibilité pluriannuel sur les
tac et quotas
le bleu du pavillon tricolore des
armateurs de france
le bleu de notre économie littoral
portuaire nautique et touristique
fleuron de notre économie vendéenne
hexagonal et ultramarine le bleu blanc
et rouge du pavillon des navires
régalien de l'état français qui
affirmeront demain notre souveraineté
sur les cinq continents et les 11
millions de kilomètres carrés de notre
espace maritime nationale monsieur le
premier ministre
à l'heure où tout devient vert sauf les
feux de la croissance et de l'emploi
osez le bleu osé regarder l'avenir de la
france en bleu quel acte fort
votre gouvernement va-t-il enfin poser
pour réaffirmé l'ambition maritime de la
france et pour se saisir de l'énorme
gisement d'emplois et de croissance que
représente notre économie maritime
merci monsieur moreau la parole et de
monsieur le secrétaire d'état aux
transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député vous avez raison de rappeler au
moment où il ya le grand débat sur la
coop l'importance de la mer l'importance
de la croissance bleue aussi pour notre
pays c'est ce que nous avons fait avec
le premier ministre il ya quelques
semaines à boulogne nous n'avons pas
simplement fait des déclarations mais
annoncer des mesures importantes qui ont
été salués quelques jours après vous le
savez lors des assises de la mer à
marseille nous avons essayé de répondre
aux attentes des armateurs de la filière
industrielle par des mesures très
pratique notamment ce qu'on appelle la
coface inversé c'est à dire la
possibilité de garantir les conditions
d'emprunt pour toute la filière
industrielle nous avons essayé
d'améliorer aussi les conditions de
compétitivité de sécurité aussi sur les
navires et puis il ya toute la question
que vous posez à chaque fois cette année
je partage avec vous la préoccupation
nous avons souvent l'occasion d'échanger
de la négociation sur la pêche la
position de la france qui a été rappelé
j'ai reçu le commissaire européen de la
pêche pour le sensibiliser si c'était
nécessaire il ya quelques jours sur
notre littoral
la position de la france est
effectivement de demander à ce qu'il y
ait des quotas pluriannuel car pour les
pêcheurs pour leur organisation vous
savez très bien aujourd'hui que la
situation est très complexe
en deux jours et deux nuits il faut
négocier sur l'ensemble des espèces
les propositions sont connus aujourd'hui
elle relève de d'avis scientifiques
elles sont difficiles mais elle était
déjà l'année dernière les résultats
avaient été plus performants donc le
gouvernement est tout à fait mobilisés
et nous le faisons en respectant nos
engagements
les engagements des pêcheurs en france
ils sont effectivement de mettre en
oeuvre la politique commune de la pêche
pour arriver à ce que l'on appelle le
rendement minimum durable c'est à dire
que ce que l'on pêche sera une année ne
mettra pas en cause la ressource c'est
un engagement des pêcheurs des anciens
gouvernements du gouvernement actuel et
je pense que nous avançons mais il faut
aussi que l'europe comprenne que nous
avons jusqu'à l'horizon 2020 qu'il faut
prendre en compte les conséquences
socio-économiques ce sera la position de
la france dans cette négociation avec
les soutiens des pêcheurs j'espère de
toute la représentation nationale
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe socialiste république